The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right.
Welcome to our second
lecture on what
to do when you have
an NP-hard problem.
So two lectures ago we saw how
to prove a problem is NP-hard.
Last lecture we saw if
you want polynomial time
but you're willing to put up
with a not perfect solution,
but you want to get within
some factor of the best
solution, that's
approximation algorithms.
Today we're going to do
a different thing called
fixed parameter algorithms.
These are going to run an
exponential time in the worst
case.
But not so bad in a certain
sense, which we'll get to.
In general, the theme of these
last two lectures and this one
is that we'd really like
to solve hard problems.
We'd like to solve them fast,
meaning polynomial time.
And we would like correct
solutions, also known
as exact solutions.
OK.
We'd love to solve NP-hard
problems in polynomial time
exactly.
But that's not possible
unless P equals nP.
So pick any two.
That's the general idea.
This is a bastardization of a
joke which is-- sleep, friends,
work-- pick any two.
That's the MIT motto.
Here in algorithms-- hard,
fast, exact-- pick any two.
So most of this class is about
these two-- polynomial time
algorithms give
you exact things.
That's the class P. Last
lecture was about hard problems.
We drop exactness.
We still want polynomial time.
We still want to
solve hard problems.
So this is approximation
algorithms.
And what we're doing today
is the other combination.
So we want exact,
but we're going
to sacrifice how
fast things are.
They're not going to
be polynomial time
in a strict sense,
but it's going
to be somewhere in between
polynomial and exponential.
This is an area called FPT for
fixed parameter tractability.
So what's this
parameter business?
In general, the idea is that we
really want an exact solution
to an NP-hard
problem, which means
it has to take exponential
time in the worst case.
But we want to confine
the exponential dependence
to something called a parameter.
OK.
We actually use
parameters all the time.
For example, on a graph,
there's two typical parameters
you think about-- the
number of vertices
and the number of edges.
If you're sorting an array, the
usual parameter you think about
is the size of the array.
OK.
That's all I mean.
A parameter, in general, is just
some kind of size or complexity
measure.
So in general, a
parameter is going
to be-- we're going
to call it k of x--
should be a non-negative
integer-- and x is the input.
So you're thinking
about some problem,
like a problem we'll
be looking at today
is vertex cover, which we
saw in the last lecture.
Vertex cover--
you're given a graph.
And based on that
graph, we're going
to define some
function of that graph.
So this is the input
to the problem,
and k is just going to be some
non-negative integer, which
is a function of that input.
Just some measure of how
tough your problem is.
OK.
And what we would
like is a running time
that is exponential in k, but
polynomial in everything else.
Polynomial in the size of
the problem, in v and E. OK.
So that's the general goal
is-- polynomial in the problem
size-- which we usually
call n-- and exponential
in the parameter--
which I'm calling-- just
going to call k--
in general, you
could consider more
parameters, but we're
just going to think of two--
the overall size of the problem,
and some particular parameter
that we look at called k.
So if you can
achieve this, which
we'll call fixed
parameter tractability--
I'll define it formally
in a little bit,
because there's
more than one way
you might think of defining it.
Some are right.
Some are wrong.
If you can achieve
this, what you get
is an exact algorithm
for your problem
that runs really fast
provided k is small.
So this is sort of a
way of saying, well,
you know the problem
is NP-hard in general,
but as long as this measure
k is reasonably small,
I'm still able to
solve it really fast.
So it's a way of
characterizing a wide family
of-- a big subset of the
problem that you can solve.
You know that in general you're
going to need exponential time,
but this gives you a measure
of how hard your input is.
May not be the only measure.
May not be the best
one, in any sense.
But if you can
define a parameter,
and you know that in
your practical scenarios
that parameter will be
small, then you're golden.
Then you can actually
solve the problem
in a reasonable amount of time
and get an exact solution.
No approximation here.
So that's the idea.
So that was a parameter.
We're also going to define
a parameterized problem.
This is just a problem
plus a parameter.
OK.
So we already have some
notions of problems.
We can take any problem
that we've looked
at before, like vertex cover.
And if we just define
some parameter,
then we get a
parameterized problem
when we put these
things together.
And usually we would
write it as something
like, oh, take this problem,
and then consider it
with respect to this parameter.
And in general, for
a single problem,
there may be several
natural parameters
that you want to care about.
Usually there's actually
one obvious parameter.
So let's do that
for vertex cover.
But in general, we can talk
about a problem with respect
to different parameters.
And some of them may be
feasible to solve in this sense.
Some maybe not.
All right.
So I'm going to
define k vertex cover.
This is almost the
same as vertex cover.
It just has a k in front.
But the k means that it's a
parameterized problem instead
of just a general problem.
So as in vertex cover,
we're given a graph G.
And I'm going to
think of the decision
version of vertex cover.
So we're given a
non-negative integer k.
And we want to know-- is there
a vertex cover of size k-- say,
less than or equal to k--
is there a vertex cover?
Remember a vertex cover
is a set of vertices
that cover all the edges.
And we want the size of S to
be less than or equal to k.
OK.
So every for every
edge, we need to choose
one of the two end points.
We want the total number of
chosen vertices to be, at most,
k.
And so that's a regular
decision problem.
But for parameterized
problem, we also
want to define a
parameter function.
And that parameter
function-- guess what?
k.
Most obvious thing, given that
I wrote the letter k here.
That's going to
be our parameter.
OK.
And most problems, a lot
of problems, especially
decision versions of
optimization problems--
like before, we were
minimizing the vertex cover--
this is the decision
version where
we want to decide whether
there's one of size of most k.
If you can solve
this, of course,
you can binary search on k,
like you did in your quiz.
Hopefully.
So that's all good.
And a lot of problems have
this some non-negative integer
floating around.
And that's the, kind
of the, obvious choice
for the parameter.
Doesn't have to be the only one.
But today, we're just going
to look at vertex cover
with this parameterization.
In your problem set, you'll
look at another problem
with another natural parameter.
This is usually called
the natural parameter.
But there's no formal
definition of natural.
That's just intuition.
All right.
So that's the set up.
Let's do some algorithms.
I guess the first note is
that k can actually be small.
Nice example is a star graph.
So you have the vertices, but
what's the smallest vertex
cover?
1.
Everyone's holding
up one finger.
You choose this guy--
that in the center,
that covers all the edges.
So it can be that k is
much smaller than v,
and our goal here
is that we're going
to get some
polynomial dependence
in the size of the
graph, but we're
going to get an exponential
dependence on k.
Now there are many
different ways
you could think of
exponential dependence,
but let's start
with-- what would
be the really obvious brute
force solution to vertex cover?
OK.
I want exact.
I'm not going to be clever.
What's the obvious
algorithm to solve this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Try any
combination of k vertices,
and see if it's a vertex cover.
ERIK DEMAINE: Try any
combination of k vertices.
See if it's a vertex cover.
How many combinations
of k vertices are there?
And choose k.
Good.
Let's see.
I'm a little out of practice.
It's been awhile.
Close.
Off by one.
So try all and choose k.
I guess, v choose k,
subsets of k vertices.
If I wanted to match
this definition exactly,
I should try all subsets of less
than or equal to k vertices.
But, hey, if I choose
fewer than k vertices,
why not add in a few
extras until I get up to k.
So it's enough to look
at v choose k subsets,
because-- subsets
of size exactly
k-- because that will end
up giving the same answer
as this question.
OK.
So for each-- test each of
those choices for coverage.
So that just means
we loop over--
I guess for every
vertex in our set,
we mark all of the
incident edges as covered.
And then we go
through all the edges,
and see whether every
one got marked covered.
If not, we reset and
try the next subset.
OK.
This is like not smart
dynamic programming.
You just guess
what the subset is.
And see if it covers.
This is how you would prove
that this problem is in NP.
Right?
But now we're actually making
it an exponential algorithm.
So what's the running
time of this algorithm?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: E times v to the k.
ERIK DEMAINE: E
times v to the k.
Good.
Must be.
So that's obviously exponential.
In a certain sense, the
dependence on E and v
is in the bottom, which is good.
And the k is in the
exponent, which makes sense.
So this is not surprising.
We also don't think
of it as good.
We've defined this to be bad.
OK.
In general, we think of
a running time like n
to the f of k, where n is sort
of the overall problem size
here.
Here n is basically v plus E.
And that's the overall input
size for a graph.
If we have a running time
where the exponent of n
depends on k, in
a nontrivial way,
we think of that as
a bad running time.
This is a slow algorithm.
It's slow because
even when k equals 2--
if you have a large
graph-- this is probably
not something you want to run.
Definitely when k is 10,
you're completely hosed.
This is a very impractical.
And the formal sense in
which it is impractical
is that the exponent
in n depends on k.
In general, you cannot say--
so I'd like to-- I mean fixed
parameter.
The whole point is to
think of the parameter
as being fixed, like a constant.
OK.
Now if the parameter is fixed.
If you think of
it as at most 100,
then, indeed, this will be at
most n to the 101 or something.
So it is polynomial
for any fixed k.
The catch is that the exponent
of the polynomial depends on k.
As you increase k, as you
increase your bound on k,
the exponent increases.
I can't say this is an n squared
algorithm for any fixed k.
OK.
So exponent depends on k.
That's the bad case.
So the good case,
we're going to define,
is that the exponent
doesn't depend on k.
That may seem like
a small change.
It is a small change.
But it's a big one.
It's a small change
with a big effect.
So I'm going to define, let's
say, a parameterized problem is
fixed parameter
tractable-- which,
given how many letters that
is, we're going to abbreviate
to FPT-- if it can be solved in
f of k times polynomial in n.
OK.
Because this means
that the exponent here
doesn't depend on anything.
The exponent of n
doesn't depend on k.
OK.
So for this definition--
just to be explicit--
I want the constant here to
be independent-- of course,
it should be
independent of n, and it
should be independent of k.
This can be any function.
It's presumably an
exponential function,
because if this is
an NP-hard problem,
something's got
to be exponential.
This clearly is not exponential.
So it's got to be here.
So this is a sense in which
we're exponential in k,
polynomial in n.
But it's much better than
this kind of running time.
OK.
We can think about
what-- in the sense
in which it is much better once
we have an actual algorithm
of this type.
So let's do-- let's
try to solve vertex
cover in this kind of time.
I claim vertex cover is
fixed parameter tractable.
There is such an algorithm.
And the algorithm is
going to look familiar.
Very similar to the
2-approximation algorithm
that we had last class
for vertex cover.
So-- but I'm going to give
it a different name, which
is bounded-search-tree.
OK.
This algorithm is also going to
feel like dynamic programming.
Or we're going to use guessing.
In general,
exponential algorithms,
naturally is guessing.
But here, when I guess, I have
to try all the possibilities.
Here this was one way of
trying all the possibilities.
We're going to be a little
bit more sophisticated in how
we try all the possibilities
that actually exploits
the properties of vertex cover.
First line is just like the
2-approximation algorithm.
Look at any edge in the graph.
OK.
Here it is.
From u to v. What do I
know about that picture?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: One of those vertices
has to be in the cover.
ERIK DEMAINE: One
of those vertices
has to be in the cover.
Either u or v or both are in
S for that edge to be covered.
Now for the 2-approximation,
we just put those both in.
Here we can't afford
to do that because we
want an exact solution.
So we'll try both options.
We don't know which one belongs.
Let's guess.
So we know either u is in S or
v is in S. Don't know which.
So guess.
Sorry-- I should, to be
clear, mention or both.
So we're going to
guess, which means
we need to try both options.
We're going to try putting
u in, and then we're
going to try putting v in.
So let's just see what
happens when we try that.
So in the first guess, we
say, let's put u in S. OK.
Well, if we put u in
S, that means we cover
all of the edges incident to u.
So I'd like to use recursion.
I'd like to simplify my problem.
Get another vertex
cover instance.
So in order to do
that, I'm just going
to delete u and all
of its incident edges.
We do the similar thing in
the approximation algorithm
but for u and v simultaneously.
So delete u as incident edges.
Now we have a vertex
cover instance.
There's one other thing.
There's a new graph we have.
But we also need to update k.
Because we just
used one of those--
we just added something
to S, and then
we deleted that from the graph.
Which means, in our new
graph, effectively k
has gone down by 1.
OK.
So I'll say decrement k.
Now I have a new instance.
I have a new graph and
a different value of k.
Recurse this algorithm.
I would say-- I'll call the new
graph G prime and the integer
k prime. k prime
equals k minus 1.
And then the second case
is do the same thing
for v. I won't write the
code, exactly the same,
but I delete v and
it's incident edges.
I still decrement k by 1.
And I recurse.
And then I just return the
or of these two answers.
So if this one finds
a solution, great.
I found a solution to
the overall problem.
This one finds a
solution, great.
Maybe both return yes.
Doesn't matter.
In general, I just
take the inclusive
or of those two Boolean values.
That gives me an overall yes
no answer to k vertex cover.
Cool?
So next question is what
the running time is.
But you can think of this
as a dynamic program.
It's just, here we recurse,
and we don't bother memoizing.
Because, in general, memoization
will never help us here.
And you may have even
thought of algorithms
like this in the dynamic
programming world.
And we just say, well,
that's not good enough,
because in dynamic programming
we want polynomial time.
This is like a dynamic
program, but the running time
is exponential.
But it turns out it will be
fixed parameter tractable.
That's the good news.
Let's think about
the running time.
So if I draw-- let's
draw a recursion tree.
Right?
This is a divide-and-conquer
algorithm in a very weak sense.
We start up here with a problem
of size n and a parameter k.
And we make two recursive calls.
OK.
We deleted a vertex
and maybe some edges.
So let's say, we
have a new problem
of size something
like n minus 1.
But what really saves us
is that k went down by 1.
And we have two recursive calls.
Each of them k is 1 smaller.
OK.
And then each of those
has two recursive calls.
I don't really know
what happens to n.
It probably doesn't
get that much smaller,
but k goes down by another 1.
OK.
So I'm writing here the
size of the problems
and the parameters
of the problems.
n minus 2.
k minus 2.
OK.
How much time do I spend
in each of these nodes?
How much work am I
doing-- non-recursive work
am I doing in this algorithm?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: o of E,
right? [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: o of E. Yeah.
Certainly at most
order E. Probably
at most order v, because
there's only at most v incident
edges to each vertex.
Yeah?
Linear time.
Doesn't really matter
how careful we are here,
but I will say-- each of
these nodes-- we spend,
at most, let's
say, order v time.
OK.
It happened that
v went down by 1.
As you can see at these levels.
But certainly an upper
bound is the original v.
In each of these nodes, we spend
at most the original v. When
does this recursion stop?
I didn't write a base case.
Help me out.
What's a good base case
for this algorithm?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: When k equals 0,
check if there are any edges.
ERIK DEMAINE: When k equals
0, check if there any edges.
When k equals 0, I can't put
anything into my vertex cover.
So if there any edges, they're
not going to be covered.
That's bad news.
OK.
So over here we have base case,
k equals 0, check-- or let's
say, return whether
size of E is not 0.
If it's not 0--
sorry-- whether it
equals 0-- get it
right-- if it equals 0,
then the answer is yes.
There's a vertex cover.
I can cover all of those
0 edges using 0 vertices.
That's good.
But when E does not
equal 0, there's
no way I can cover that
non-zero number of edges using
0 vertices in my vertex cover.
OK.
So that's the base
case, which means
this recursion keeps going
until we get down to k equals 0.
We start at k.
We end up with 0.
So the number of
levels here is k.
OK.
The height of this tree--
this recursion tree is k.
So how many nodes are
there in this tree?
2 to the k.
So total running time
is v times 2 to the k.
I guess I should write
2 to the k times v. Hey,
that is exactly what I wanted.
I got a function of
k-- namely 2 to the k.
Exponential-- that makes sense.
And I got a polynomial in n.
Here it's n.
The exponent is 1.
v is at most n. n
us v plus E. Wow.
Big improvement.
This seems equally simple
of an algorithm as this one,
but actually it
runs a lot faster.
OK.
Let me give you a
feeling-- I mean
this is what we would call a
linear time algorithm for fixed
k.
The exponent here
doesn't depend on k.
If k is 10, it's a
linear time algorithm.
If k is 100, it's a
If k is 100, that
might be a little bit
beyond what we can run.
But you know, k
equals 32, 40 maybe,
that would probably be
reasonable running time,
in practice.
OK.
That's a lot better than before
where like k equals 2 or 3.
This is probably unreasonable.
v is like a billion,
say, big graph.
Also from a theoretical
perspective,
this works even up
to k equals log n.
If k equals log n,
this'll be n squared.
That's nice.
k equals 2 log n, it's n cubed.
OK.
So it grows.
But we can handle k
equals order log n.
And this will still
be polynomial.
In general, with fixed
parameter algorithms,
it's not always going
to be up to log n,
it's going to be up to whatever
the inverse of this f of k is.
That's where we can
still be polynomial.
So that's nice.
I consider this a
good running time.
Good in the sense that it
follows that definition
of fixed parameter tractable.
So bounded-search-tree
algorithm is good.
Brute force algorithm is bad.
In this case.
Bounded-search-tree is
a general technique.
You can use it for
lots of problems.
We're going to see
another technique
today called kernelization.
But-- Let's see--
before I get there,
I want to question
this definition.
So this definition is nice.
It's natural in the
sense that it gives you--
it distinguishes between the
exponent of n depending on k
and not depending on k, which
is a natural thing to do.
But there's another natural
definition of fixed parameter
tractability.
So let's-- vertex cover-- I
think you remember the problem
by now.
So let's see-- we have
this definition, which
is f of k times polynomial n.
But I would say that the first
time I saw fixed parameter
tractability, I thought, well,
why do you define it that way?
I mean, maybe it would be better
to do f of k plus polynomial n.
That would be better, right?
That would be
faster, seems like.
So I mean, this is nice in
that we achieved this bound,
but could we hope for
this even better bound.
OK?
It turns out these
notions are identical.
This is weird.
The first time you see it.
So theorem-- you can solve a
problem in this kind of time,
if and only if you can solve the
problem in this kind of time.
So of course, f is
going to change.
And why don't I label
these constants.
So we have c up here and
some c prime up here.
But you can solve a problem
in this multiplicative time,
if and only if you can
solve it in an additive time
with a different function
and a different constant.
This is actually
really easy to prove.
The longer you think about it,
the more obvious it will be.
If you have an instance of
size n with parameter k,
there are two cases.
Either n is less than
or equal to f of k,
or n is greater than
or equal to f of k.
Right?
It's got to be one
of those, maybe both.
If n is less than or
equal to f of k that
means that this running time,
f of k times n to the c--
let's see-- n is at most f of k.
So this is at most f of
k to the c plus 1 power.
Right?
I multiply f of k to
the c times f of k.
When n is greater
than f of k, then
I know that this running time,
f of k times n to the c, well,
now I know an upper
bound of f of k.
I know this thing is at most n.
And so this is at most
n to the c plus 1.
OK.
So really I have two
scenarios, either I'm
bounded by some
purely function of k,
or I'm bounded by some
purely polynomial of n.
Which means, in both cases,
the running time f of k times
n to the c is bounded
above by the max
of those two things, max of
f of k to the c plus 1, n
to the c plus 1.
OK.
And the max is always,
at most, the sum.
I'm assuming everything
here is non-negative.
So I take f of k, c plus
1, plus n to the c plus 1.
Boom.
That is an additive function
of k plus polynomial in n.
OK.
Rather trivial.
This a funny area
where you think,
ah, this is deep question.
Are these things the same?
And ends up, yeah, they're
the same for obvious reasons.
So for example, we have this
linear, basically n times 2
to the k algorithm.
If you apply this
argument, you get
this is, at most, so this
n times to the k bound,
is, at most, n squared
plus 4 to the k.
OK.
I'm basically just
squaring both of the terms.
OK.
Probably you prefer
this time bound,
but if you really like
an additive time bound,
the exact same algorithm
satisfies this.
OK.
So not that exciting.
And in practice, n squared--
it looks like a bad thing,
so you'd probably prefer
this kind of running time.
But there is a sense-- there's
a quadratics thing going
on here in that we
have an n and then
we have a function
of k multiplied
together-- OK-- whatever.
All right.
So this justifies
the definition.
This is kind of robust to
whether I put a dot here
or plus, so clearly this
is the right definition.
We're going to use dot.
You could also use
plus, but-- all right.
But there's another thing
called kernelization,
which, in an intuitive sense,
matches this idea of plus.
And it also matches
an idea that's
common practice
called pre-processing.
If I have a giant graph,
and I'm given some number k,
and I want to find
a vertex cover,
well, maybe the first thing I
could do is simplify my graph.
Maybe there's some parts that
are really easy to solve.
I should throw those away first.
And that will make
my problem smaller.
So if I'm going to have an
exponential running time,
presumably, I want to first make
the problem as small as I can.
Then deal with one
of these algorithms.
OK.
So we're going to do that.
First, I'm going to tell
you about it generically.
And then we'll do
it for vertex cover.
So first, let me
give you a definition
of what we'd like out of this
pre-processing procedure.
It's going to be called a
kernelization procedure.
Kernelization algorithm is
a polynomial time algorithm.
Head back to
polynomial time land.
You can think of
it as a reduction,
but with NP-hardness, we
reduced from one problem a
to another problem b.
Here we're going to
reduce from the problem
a to the same problem a.
It's a self reduction,
if you will.
But the input to the problem
is going to get smaller.
So we're going to
convert an input.
So this is for a
parameterized problem.
So an input consists
of some regular input
x and a parameter k.
And we want to convert it into
an equivalent small input x
prime k prime to
the same problem.
OK.
The problem is fixed,
say vertex cover.
So we're given an
arbitrary input.
This would be a
graph and a number k.
And we want to convert it into
an equivalent small input,
which is another graph G prime,
and another parameter k prime.
So equivalent means that the
answer is going to be the same.
OK.
And I want the answer
to the problem--
let's say, answer of x comma
k to be equal to the answer
to x prime and k prime.
Again, same problem,
but different input.
I'm trying to be a
little generic here.
It could be-- we're
going to think here
about decision problems,
but this makes sense
even for non-decision problems.
Whatever the answer is
here, it should be the same
as the answer is here, because
I want an exact solution.
I want to solve
exactly the problem.
I want to compute this
answer exactly correctly.
So if I can reduce
it to some x prime k
prime with the same
answer, well, now I
can just solve x prime k prime.
So that's good.
Now what does small mean?
We need to define both of these.
Small means that
the size of x prime,
which you might call
n prime, should be,
at most, some function of k.
Cool.
So this is interesting.
So we started with probably
a giant problem, x excise n,
and we have a parameter k, which
we presume is relatively small.
And we convert it
into a new input x
prime that's very small.
Its size is a function of k.
No more dependence on n. n has
disappeared from the problem.
OK.
We start with
something a size n.
We produced something the
size as function of k.
And then-- OK-- there's
some other parameter k
prime-- doesn't matter
much what it is.
It's going to also
be a function of k.
So we started with
something of size n.
We produced something of size k.
In polynomial time.
Wow.
This would be big
if we could do it.
Because we start with
giant problem small k,
and we kernelize
it down-- so here's
the picture with this big thing.
And the intuition is that
the hardness of the problem
is just from this
thing of size k.
But there's no thing of size k.
Or at least we haven't
found it yet, right?
The k is the size of the
vertex cover we're looking for.
But we don't know where that is.
It's hiding somewhere
in this instance,
in this amorphous blob.
So it's k.
But somehow, magically,
this kernelization procedure
produces a new problem that's
only a little bit bigger
than k.
OK.
Some function of k.
So we take the big
problem, we make it
down to this small thing.
What do you do now?
You can run any
algorithm you want,
any finite algorithm
applied to this instance
will run in some
function of k time.
Doesn't matter as long as
this is a correct algorithm.
If your problem is in NP,
there is an exponential time
algorithm.
You just try all the guesses.
So we could use-- we
have two of them here.
We could run either of these
after we've kernelized.
And we would get an FPT time.
And, indeed, the FPT would
mimic this kind of running time.
We do a polynomial
amount of pre-processing.
That's the
kernelization procedure.
That's the only dependence on n.
After we've done
that, the new problem
is entirely a function of k.
And then you apply
any algorithm to that,
you'll get f of k running time.
Now if we want a good
f of k, we should
use the best algorithm we have.
But, in general, you
could use anything.
All right.
So far, so good.
So we had this theorem that
product is the same as plus.
In fact, kernelization
is the same thing.
So these are all the same thing.
I guess this one is
equivalent to being FPT.
that's the definition of FPT.
So I'll just write it here.
The problem is FPT, if and
only if it has a kernelization.
This is crazy.
I keep introducing stronger
and stronger notions of good.
And they all turn
out to be the same.
That, again, gives you
a sense of robustness
of this definition.
And why this is a
natural thing to study.
So this sounds crazy.
How could I put all
of the easy work
at the beginning in this
polynomial time algorithm
and then in the end
produce something
that is a reasonable size?
Again, this proof is
going to be trivial.
I think everything in
this field is either
really hard or trivial.
I guess that makes sense.
So let's first-- so I'm just
looking at this inequality--
this implication-- we
already did the other one.
The easy direction, of
course, is this way.
I didn't even do
it in this case.
If I have an additive
running time,
it certainly, at
most, the product,
assuming both those
numbers are at least 1.
OK.
And again, if I have a
kernelization, as I said,
I could run the kernelization
algorithm in polynomial time,
and then run any finite
algorithm to solve the problem,
and I would get some
f of k running time.
So this is easy.
Kernelize and then run any
algorithm on the kernel.
Kernel is the produced
output x prime k prime.
OK.
Let's do the other direction.
That's the interesting part.
So suppose I have it an
algorithm that runs, let's say,
in this running time.
I claim that I can
turn it into a kernel.
And the proof is going
to look just like before.
OK.
So there are two cases.
One is that f of k, let's say,
is less than or equal to n.
Actually I want to do
the other case first.
I think it's a
little more natural.
Well, it doesn't really matter.
They're both easy but
for different reasons.
the then parts are
going to look different.
So the first case,
if n is at most
f of k, what do I do in that
situation, in other words,
kernelize of this
thing of size n,
I want to kernelize into
something of size f of k?
Nothing.
I'm done already.
So this is the already
kernelized case.
That's great.
So the other cases,
and it's big.
That's the more interesting
case, of course.
n is greater than
or equal to f of k.
What happens here?
Well, just like last time, that
means that this running time, f
of k is now at most n, that
means this running times
is at most n to the c plus one.
Right?
So that means the FPT
algorithm that I'm given,
because we're
assuming here we're
given an FPT algorithm,
we want to produce
a kernel-- in that
case, that algorithm
runs in n to the c plus 1 time.
Which means I can
actually run it.
That's polynomial time.
OK.
So over here I needed a
polynomial time kernelization
algorithm.
If it happens that
f of k is at most n,
then I can actually
run the FPT algorithm,
and that would be a valid
kernelization procedure.
Now the FPT algorithm
actually solves the problem.
Let's say, it says
yes or no, whether the
answer to my original question.
The kernelization procedure
has to output an input
to the problem.
So what I need to
add one thing here
which is just-- output a
canonical yes or no input
accordingly.
OK.
If the FPT algorithm-- here
I'm thinking about decision
problems-- if the FPT
algorithm says yes,
I'm going to output
one instance,
one input of the problem
where the output is yes.
I know that one exists, because
this algorithm said yes.
So in a constant
amount of space,
I'm able to write a yes input.
Or in a constant amount
space, I write a no input.
So the new kernel will
have constant size,
which is smaller than f of k.
OK.
That's it.
So either I output the same
input that I was given.
Or I output something
of constant size
that encodes a yes or no.
Kind of trivial again.
The catch is that size of the
kernel, the size of the output,
in general, here is going
to be exponential in k,
because f of k presumably
is exponential in k.
That's annoying.
This is what you might call
an exponential size kernel.
So an interesting question.
And exponential size kernels
are equivalent to FPT.
Something that may
not be equivalent
is a polynomial size kernel.
It would be nice if I
start with something that's
polynomial in n, and I
reduce it to something
that's polynomial in k.
And then I run something
that's exponential on that.
But it will only be singly
exponential in k, hopefully.
Whereas, if I use this
kernelization procedure,
if I apply to vertex cover
with one of these algorithms,
I'm going to get
a new thing that's
size is exponential in k.
If I run one of these
brute force algorithms,
I'm going to get
something that's like
doubly exponential in k.
That's not so hot,
because I know
how to do exponential in k.
All right.
But this is the general idea of
kernelization, and why it's not
surprising that you can do it.
I have one catch here which
is-- this is an algorithm.
It compares n to f of k.
In order to do this, you
have to know what k is.
Minor technicality.
If you don't know what
k is, you can basically
run this algorithm with
a timer, a stopwatch,
and if it's running time
exceeds n to the c plus 1,
then you know you're
not in this case.
If it finishes within
that time bound, great.
You found the answer.
If it doesn't finish, then you
know you must be in this case,
and then you just quit, and
output your original input
and say, I'm kernelized.
Done.
Easy.
OK.
That's a technicality.
All right.
So much for general theory.
Let's go back to algorithms.
Yeah, all this work I want
to write down over here.
We have a v times 2
to the k algorithm.
On the one side.
And here, we have an E
as v to the k algorithm.
Just want to keep
a running-- we're
going to get a faster
algorithm than both of those
through kernelization.
So I claim that we can
find a polynomial kernel--
polynomial-sized
kernel-- it's going to be
quadratic for vertex cover.
These are hard to find.
And there's a whole
research industry
for finding polynomial kernels.
So I'm going to give
you some methods.
But they're specific
to vertex cover.
So here's the first thing.
This is hard to draw.
So here I have a
vertex u, and suppose
I have an edge
connected from u to u.
This is called a loop.
What can I do from a
vertex cover perspective?
What can I conclude
about this picture?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
You must be in the vertex cover,
because this edge really only
has one endpoint.
OK.
So far, so easy.
So what I can do in
this case is say,
OK, u is in the vertex cover,
and then delete u at it's
incident edges.
So-- and then we
have to decrement k.
OK.
Cool.
Seems-- feels familiar.
But in this case,
there's no guessing.
We just know you
must be in the cover.
All right.
Here's another case.
Suppose I have u and v and there
are many edges connecting them.
This is called a multi-edge.
So maybe you just assume
your graph is simple.
But if you don't assume
your graph is simple,
we might have these
kinds of situations.
What can I do in this case?
What can I guarantee?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You can
remove all but one edge.
ERIK DEMAINE: You can remove
all but one of the edges.
Let's just delete all but one.
If I cover one of
them, I cover them all.
Easy peasy.
See if you get the other rules.
So delete all by 1.
In general, we're
going to have a bunch
of these kinds of simplification
rules are guaranteed correct.
They don't change the output.
But magically, we're going
to end up with something
the size of function of k.
We haven't done much yet.
But now we know that the
graph is simple, meaning it
has no loops and it
has no multi-edges.
Cool.
All right.
Next thing I want to think
about is a vertex of degree
greater than k. k is
the current value of k.
So suppose I have a high
degree vertex, more than k,
edges out going from it.
What can I say then?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You must pick it.
ERIK DEMAINE: You must
put it in the cover.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because then
you need to cover all
the remaining error vertices.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
Proof by contradiction.
If I don't put it in the cover,
that means all of these guys
are in the cover.
There's more than k of them.
And the whole goal was to find a
vertex cover of size at most k.
So you better not put all of
these in your vertex cover,
because that's more than k.
So, therefore, this
one has to be in there.
This is a cool argument.
Simple, but cool.
OK.
So any vertex of
degree greater than k
must be in the vertex cover,
which I was calling S. OK.
So delete that vertex and its
incident edges, decrement k,
because we just used something.
OK.
So just keep doing this.
Every time I see a vertex
of degree more than k,
delete it, decrement k.
Now I have a new graph
and a new value of k.
Look for any vertices whose
degree is more than k.
If I find one, delete
it, repeat, repeat.
Keep repeating until
you can't anymore.
How much time is
this going to take?
I don't know.
Most quadratic, right?
I look at all the vertices.
Look at their degrees.
I could look over all the
edges, increment the degrees.
In linear time, I can
find whether there's
any vertex of
degree more than k.
Then delete it in linear time.
Then try again.
And this will happen to
most linear time many times
because I can only
delete a vertex once.
So I delete at most v vertices.
So overall running time here
is like at most v times E,
polynomial.
Probably if you're clever,
use a data structure
to update degrees.
You could do this
in order v time.
But let's not be clever yet.
All right.
So now, after I've done
all of these reductions,
I have a graph where every
vertex has degree at most k.
So it's like a
bounded degree graph.
Why do I care about a
bounded degree graph?
Remember, I drew this example,
which was a star graph,
where n was large, but k was
very small. n was n, n was v,
and k was 1.
Now a star graph is
special because it
has a very high degree vertex.
In general, if I have a
vertex of some degree, say k,
and I put it in the vertex
cover, it covers k edges.
OK.
So each vertex in S
covers at most k edges,
wherever the degree is.
So that means you don't get
much bang for your buck anymore.
We've already taken care of all
the high degree vertices where
you get a lot of
reward for putting
one vertex in the cover.
Now this is the new value of k.
It may have decremented
from before.
Every vertex that we could
possibly put in the set
will only cover k edges.
Now we know that
we only get to put
k more vertices into the set.
We know-- we're supposing
that sides of S is at most k.
So that means that the
number of edges, size of E,
must be at most k squared.
All right.
Because every one I put into
S covers at most k edges.
All of them have to be covered.
And so k times k is k squared.
Hah, interesting.
That means my graph is small.
Now slight catch.
There might be a whole
bunch of vertices that
have no edges incident to them.
So I need to delete
isolated vertices.
Let's say, degree 0 vertices.
OK.
Degree 0 vertices-- you
really don't want to put those
into your vertex cover.
No point.
They don't cover any edges.
So delete those.
And now, I still may not
have a connected graph,
but, in the worst case,
I have a matching.
I know the total number of
edges is at most case squared.
That means the total
number of vertices
is at most twice
that, 2k squared.
So after all of
these operations,
I assumed that S
was size at most k.
And then if I do all
of these operations,
I get a graph with at most 2k
squared vertices, and at most
case k squared edges.
So the total size
of the graph, which
I'm calling n, n which is
size of v plus size of E
is order k squared.
3k squared.
And I assumed that there was
a vertex cover size at most k
throughout this.
So what I do is I run this
kernelization algorithm.
And I see-- is the graph
that I produced size
at most 3k squared?
If it is, output it.
That's a kernelized
thing because it's small.
If it isn't, if the
graph I've produced
is still too big, that must mean
that this assumption was wrong,
which means the answer to the
vertex cover problem is no,
there is no vertex
cover of size at most k.
And so then I just
output a canonical
no instance, like-- so I mean,
this is sort of outside--
but if the newly
produced graph-- I'll
call it v prime plus E prime is
greater than 3 times k squared,
then output-- and
here I can actually
give you one--
let's say, I'm going
to output the graph which is a
single edge with two vertices
and k equals 0.
The answer to vertex cover
in this instance is no.
So this is an example
of a constant size,
no representative.
So either I get
something that's small
and I output that, or
it's big, in which case
I output this thing, which is
to say, nope, can't be done.
That's kernelization.
So I've produced a quadratic
size graph, quadratic in k
in polynomial time.
Question?
No.
Wow.
So this is kernelization
at its finest.
A polynomial kernel.
Polynomial time.
We get that down to something
the size of polynomial in k.
This is how you should-- if
you want to solve vertex cover,
you might as well do
these reductions first,
because they will
simplify your thing.
And now, if you happen to know
your vertex cover is small,
then the graph will be small.
So now we could run either
of these algorithms.
OK.
Presumably, we should
run the better one.
But for fun, let's
analyze both of them.
OK.
So I'm going to leave
the running times here.
We're going to get a
faster vertex cover
algorithm from a fixed parameter
tractability perspective.
So here's a new FTP algorithm.
Two of them.
First we kernelize.
OK.
We spent-- I guess--
order vE time.
Again, I think you can
get that down to order v
without too much effort.
Obvious.
It's not totally obvious.
It's a good exercise.
Be a good problem set problem.
It's not on the problem set.
Don't worry.
It could be a good
final exam problem.
Probably a little long.
All right.
So now we could-- let's
say, option one-- let's
use the brute force
algorithm after that.
The running time of that
is E times v to the k.
But now E is k squared.
And v is also order k squared.
Let's not worry
about-- actually I
do have to worry about
constants here, because it's
in the base of an exponent.
So I do.
So we're going to get k
squared for the E term.
And then v term is going
to be 2 times k squared.
And that's going to be
raised to the k-th power.
OK.
So I'll simplify a little bit.
This is like 2 to the k
times-- I guess-- k to the 2k.
OK.
It's k to the k squared.
Not bad.
Overall running time
is vE plus this.
It's a function of k.
It's exponential.
Good.
We have a better algorithm.
We have this v times 2
to the k running time,
so we might as
well use that one.
But the point is--
once you kernelize,
you can use pretty
stupid algorithms,
and you still get really
good running times.
OK.
We'll get a slightly
better running time
using the bounded-tree-search.
So if we use
bounded-tree-search,
we have v. v is 2k squared.
So here the constant
doesn't matter,
because there's no exponent.
And then we have
times 2 to the k.
So we're going to get k squared
times 2 to the k algorithms.
Kind of funny symmetry here.
2 and k are switching roles.
Of course, the 2 to
the k is the big term.
But now it's only
singularly exponential in k.
This thing is like
2 to the k log k.
This thing is only 2 to the k.
So it's better.
And this is like k factorial.
And this is just 2 to the k.
So it's a big improvement.
This will be a much more
practical algorithm.
So we run the
kernelization, then
we run the
bounded-tree-search algorithm.
And so the total running time
is vE plus k squared 2 to the k.
The story doesn't end here.
There are dozens
of papers about how
to solve vertex cover from
fixed parameter tractability
perspective.
The best one so far--
I'm not going to cover--
but it is based
on kernelization.
Just more rules.
And you get k v
plus 1.274 to the k.
And some cover's better
than 2, but very similar.
That's vertex cover.
If you have a vertex
cover instance,
and you know that it's going to
have a relatively small vertex
cover, these are the
algorithms you should use.
Any questions?
This ends our
vertex cover story.
But the last thing I want to do
is connect up these two areas.
Last class we talked about
approximation algorithms.
This class we talked about
fixed parameter algorithms.
They're actually
closely related.
And so, for example, we will
get a fixed parameter algorithm
to subset sum, using what
we already had last lecture.
So, so far today, I've
basically been talking
about decision problems.
But let's think a little bit
about optimization problems.
So take your favorite
optimization problem.
Like any of the ones
from last lecture.
And let's assume that
the optimal solution
value-- the thing we're
trying to optimize, minimize,
or maximize-- is an integer.
Assume that OPT is an integer.
OK.
Now let's look at
the decision problem.
Whenever you have an
optimization problem,
you can convert it into
a decision problem.
You can convert it into a few.
For example, OPT less than or
equal to k, or OPT greater than
or equal to k.
They're all going to turn
out to work the same.
OPT equal k would also work.
Now that's a decision
problem, but what I want
is a parameterized
decision problem.
What should my parameter be?
k.
All right.
That's the obvious parameter.
In some sense, we're
parameterizing by OPT,
but we're adding a
layer of indirection.
We're saying, well,
OPT, but we want
to decide whether OPT is
less than or equal to k.
And let's parameterize by k.
That's similar flavor to what
we had with vertex cover.
If we started with minimum
vertex cover, and converted it.
Cool.
Here's the theorem.
This is not going to be as
strong as the other things
we've seen.
No equivalence here.
So it's a one way implication.
And I haven't defined this term
yet, but it's similar to one
we saw last class.
If the optimization problem
that we started with
has an efficient PTAS, an
efficient Polynomial Time
Approximation Scheme, then
the decision problem--
you get from here-- is
fixed parameter tractable
with respect to k.
OK.
So what does EPTAS mean?
It's going to look familiar.
We're going to take an
arbitrary function of 1
over epsilon times a
fixed polynomial in n.
So last time we
talked about PTAS
we could have-- you could have
something like n to the f of 1
over epsilon.
I'm going to consider that
bad, as you might imagine,
from a fixed parameter
tractability perspective.
Better would be some function,
possibly exponential,
if 1 over epsilon
times polynomial in n.
This is going to be good from
a fixed parameter perspective.
Although it's about
approximation algorithms,
not about exact algorithms.
Of course, even
better is the FPTASs
we saw last time, which is
polynomial 1 over epsilon times
polynomial in n.
That's ideal.
If you have an FPTAS,
it is also an EPTAS.
You just remove-- or you
just add one more stroke
to the first letter.
And you got an EPTAS.
And last class we
actually saw an EPTAS.
For subset sum, we saw 2 to
the 1 over epsilon times n.
Now, in fact, for that
problem, there's an FPTAS.
Even better.
But you can see
from last lecture
why it's nice to have an
exponential dependence on 1
over epsilon.
And what this is saying
is you can do that
as long as that
exponential dependence is
separated from the n part.
If it's multiplicatively
or additively separated,
as you might imagine, it's
the same thing, from n,
then we call this
an efficient PTAS.
Not fully, not quite as
good as an FPTAS, but close.
And as long as you
have such a thing,
you can convert it into an
FPT algorithm for the decision
problem.
The way this is typically
used-- so this tells us we
get an FPT algorithm
for subset sum.
In fact, because
there's an FPTAS,
we get a pseudo
polynomial time algorithm,
which is in some sense better.
Anyway.
The way this theorem is usually
used is in the contrapositive.
What this tells us is that if we
can find a problem that is not
FPT-- and there's a whole
theory like NP completeness
for showing the problems
are almost certainly not
fixed parameter
tractable-- then we
know that there is not an EPTAS.
And this is the state
of the art for proving
that these kinds of
algorithms do not exist.
Typically, you look at it from
a fixed parameter perspective,
and show that probably
doesn't exist.
Then you get that this
probably doesn't exist.
OK.
Let's prove this theorem.
It's, again, really easy.
But a nice connection
between these two worlds.
All right.
So there are two cases--
the optimization problem
we're thinking about could be
a minimization or maximization
problem.
Let's say it's maximization,
just to be concrete.
It won't make too
much difference,
but it will make
a tiny difference
in order of-- or the
inequality directions.
OK.
So what we're going to do.
So we're given an EPTAS,
and we want to solve FPT.
We want an FPT algorithm.
So what do we do?
Well, an algorithm is going
to be to run that EPTAS.
That's sort of the
only thing we can do.
Now the EPTAS-- this is
an approximation scheme.
It has an extra input
which is epsilon.
We need to choose epsilon,
because we're not--
we're trying to
solve it exactly.
But there's no epsilon
in that problem,
so we got to make one up.
Let's run the EPTAS with--
anyone have good intuition?
What should epsilon be?
Yeah.
Remind you of this.
Tricky.
We want epsilon to be small.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It should be 1 over k.
ERIK DEMAINE: 1 over
k is almost right.
Anything less than
that would work.
So I'll use 1 over 2k, but 1
over k plus 1 would also work.
Or anything a little
bit-- 1 over k--
yeah-- 1 over k plus
.00001 something.
Anything a little bit less than
1 over k will turn out to work.
So, why?
So first of all, how
much time does this take?
Well, we were given
this running time.
1 over this is 2k.
So this is going to take f of
2k time times polynomial in n.
OK.
We need to connect E
and k, because we're
given-- sorry-- epsilon
given something whose running
time depends on epsilon not k.
Now we're setting
epsilon in terms of k,
so now the running time is a
function of k, not epsilon.
And then times n.
So this is good.
This looks like an
FPT running time.
I claim we found
that the answer.
OK.
This is maybe the
surprising part.
You had good intuition here.
And the intuition is
just that-- if you're
this close to optimal, and
optimal is actually an integer,
and you found an integer, then
you're going to be less than 1
away, which means you're
actually the same thing.
OK.
But let's do it more formally.
So we're within a 1
plus epsilon factor.
I'm going to call the
epsilon part relative error.
All right.
That's how much it gets
multiplied by OPT in order
to compute the error bound.
So the relative
error is epsilon.
Epsilon is-- I guess is--
at most epsilon-- epsilon is
1 over 2k, which all
I'm going to need
is that this is strictly
less than 1 over k.
So this means if I look
at absolute error--
so in case you're not
familiar-- relative error is
I take my approximate
solution-- I subtract off,
let's say the optimal
solution, did I get this right?
This is a maximization problem.
So yeah, my solution's
presumably-- no,
it's going to be the
other way around.
For maximization
problem, it's going
to be-- the optimal
could be bigger
than me, so I take
that difference-- this
is called absolute error.
OK.
And relative error is when
I just divide that by OPT.
That's relative error.
So I have this one part already.
So usually you state it in
terms of 1 plus epsilon.
If you state it in
terms of relative error,
the 1 disappears.
You just get epsilon.
The absolute error
which is OPT minus APX
is I take the relative error
and I multiply it by OPT.
OK.
So relative error is
going to be less than 1
if OPT is-- I guess--
greater than or equal to k?
I have less than in my notes.
But if OPT is greater
than or equal to k,
then absolute error
is less than 1.
Right?
I hope.
Let's check.
The relative error is
actually OPT divided by k.
Oops.
No, I've got it the
wrong way around.
It's correct in my notes.
OK.
Relative error is this thing.
It's going to be strictly
less than OPT divided by k.
This thing times OPT.
OK.
So as long as OPT is
less than or equal to k,
this thing will be
strictly less than 1.
That's good.
OPT error less than
1 for an integer
means that we actually
have the same value.
I have that written
down more formally.
So let's go here.
So if we find an integral
solution-- of value-- values
the objective function
we're trying to maximize.
Let's say we achieve something
value less than or equal to k.
Which it better be about if
OPT is less than or equal to k.
Then OPT-- OK-- this is
basically doing the computation
again in another way.
We had 1 plus epsilon.
Epsilon's chosen
to be 1/2 1 over k.
And then k was the solution
value that we found.
And so we have this relation
between OPT and the thing.
And therefore-- and this works
out to exactly k plus 1/2.
So this is, again, strictly
less than k plus 1.
And so if we found-- we
assumed that OPT was less than
or equal to k.
And so now it must
actually be equal to k,
because there are no integers
between k and k plus 1/2.
OK.
I probably could have
done that shorter.
So when we have an EPTAS, we
exactly get an FPT algorithm.
And that's-- the
reverse does not hold.
There are some problems
that have FPT algorithms
but do not have EPTASes.
But, it's something, and it
connects these two fields.
And that's all we'll say about
fixed parameter algorithms.
Any final questions?
Cool.
See you next week.